merci vraiment d'être là c'est vrai que
cette initiative a nous a plu voilà et
vous êtes venus aujourd'hui la défendre
aussi sur notre plateau merci nous avoir
choisi le duo d comment est partie
l'idée de du duo d c'est sophie cluzel
la ministre en charge de la question du
handicap qui à la fois fait des
propositions concrètes pour faciliter la
vie pour améliorer la vie de nos
concitoyens qui sont frappés et qui sont
en situation de handicap mais qui en
même temps se bat pour banaliser la
question du handicap le regard sur le
handicap et c'est vrai que cette idée
d'iodé qui fait qu'aujourd'hui vous avez
une vingtaine de miss le président de la
république mais aussi des personnalités
comme tony estanguet ça le patron du
foot et du cojo qui va s'occuper des
jeux olympiques de paris 2024 qui sont
aujourd'hui accompagné par une personne
en situation de handicap pour banaliser
le handicap et pour montrer qu'on peut
être co présentatrice d'une émission
télé qu'on peut être un étudiant
brillant comme gérald qui m'accompagne
et que le fait d'avoir un handicap ne
vous empêche pas d'être et c'est
essentiel de le rappeler emmanuel macron
saisis dans la république ou edouard
philippe
vous préférez qui est pourquoi la photo
d'edouard philippe elle et pixellisée
comment est-ce qu'on n'avait pas
l'oseille moi je trouve que c'est très
moche ce que vous faites tous les deux
bah oui parce que j'avais réussi à faire
croire à l'un et à l'autre qu'ils
étaient mes préférés patatras vous
m'obligez à annoncer à l'un et à l'autre
les jeux que je vais m'en sortir
d'abord il y en a que je connais depuis
peu depuis que je rentre gouvernement et
dont j'apprécie l'humour l'affection
c'est vraiment une personne extrêmement
chouette c'est le premier ministre et
par philippe sauf qu emmanuel macron jeu
l'accompagnent depuis plus longtemps et
donc j'étais seul avec lui on a commencé
cet engagement politique on était 5 6
autour de lui et j'ai eu la chance
d'être là et ce que je vis aujourd'hui
qui est très extraordinaire et compris
le fait d'être ici devant vous sur le
plateau je sais que je lui dois lui elle
va donc c'est pas mal a donc préféré
devenir le patron christophe alors on a
deux
jul ou soprano ou là à la ccc marqué ces
deux marseillais
oui mais sans rappeler à nos jours tant
plus souvent chez moi
alors d'où l'on va on va rappeler c'est
à romain
vous adorez les rênes du shopping oui
alors que vous adorez cette émission a
en fait eu rarement de balaté la star là
mais si j'ai l'occasion d'abord mes
filles adorées les gammes du shopping et
donc si j'ai l'occasion je passe devant
elle savait quoi là j'aime bien et ça
c'est un scoop comme j'adore les rênes
du shopping vous allez maps et de moi
que tu es dans shake christophe au
regard des riches au ping an nicolas
sarkozy françois hollande ça c'est pas
mal prise était au ps avant d'aller au
bout et mir 1 qui s'est retiré la vie
politique qui aujourd'hui ne sont pas
obligés de dire du mal de son successeur
c'est nicolas sarkozy donc objectivement
je préfère la sagesse de celui qui a su
se retirer nicolas sarkozy au caractère
et gris de l'autre nom de la vérité ce
sont la vérité
faut dire la vérité et elle a une
dernière question najet oui alors cyril
hanouna ou yann barthès
c'est facile maman toujours appris à
être poli quand tu es reçu chez
quelqu'un tu dis merci et encore merci
si jeune je faisais beaucoup et je vais
vous dire un truc j'ai abandonné parce
que le match dans dix minutes
donc j'ai abandonné les sharp mais
depuis quand même j'ai fait mieux se
sent comme on va se retrouver
non
[Applaudissements]
ouais bravo à produire ça
avant nous porte et qu'elle sorte garde
offert le maillot du psg total
y a pas besoin de les soutenir ils
gagnent tout le temps il est fort merci
christophe cazala l'abrité